chers téléspectateurs chers compatriotes
salam aleikoum mes frères je sais que
vous attendez de moi une première mesure
très forte et je la prendrai certaines
têtes dès le premier jour de mon
élection vont tomber autour de la table
je prendrai des mesures n'oubliez jamais
voté de leurs mots c'est voter le bo je
vous laisse donc imaginer les personnes
mes chers compatriotes
[Rires]
si vous m'accordez vos suffrages
madame le premier ministre ce sera dans
la transparence ce sera je vous
l'annonçais valérie benaïm mon coeur mon
clément c'est par ces quelques mots ici
en direct sur le plateau de cyril et
devant la france entière que je souhaite
déclarer mon amour tu as 23 ans
aujourd'hui et je te souhaite que les 23
prochaines années nous les passions
ensemble je t'aime
[Applaudissements]